سوره الحجرات
هي سوره مدنيه
اجماع علماء التفسير
وهي معدوده ثمانيه عشر ايه
سوره الحجرات
سميت بذلك لذكر
الحجرات فيها
ان الذين ينادونك من وراء الحجرات وسياتي
بيان ذلك ان شاء الله
والحجرات
جمع حجره
الحجره في الغرفه
في البيت
وهذه السوره تضمنت كثيرا من الاداب التي
ينبغي لمن اراد
ان
يبني وان يكون من مبنى مجتمع
قويا رصين
مجتمع مبني على الايمان وكانه بنيان مرصوص
هذه الصوره فيها اداب وفيها اخلاق وفيها
امور ينبغي لكل واحد منا ان يتفقد نفسه
وان يقيس نفسه عليها
هذه السوره سوره الحجرات اعتبرها كثير من
العلماء
اول سوره
من سور المفصل
الحديث النبوي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قسم القران الى اربعه اقسام باعتبار
شبه هذا الكتاب هذا القران بالكتب المنزله
من قبل
فذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الطوال سبع الطوال
هن
بمكانه التوراه التي اوتيها لموسى عليه
السلام
وان المئنين
يعني السور التي
قرابت 100 ايه
او تزيد على ذلك او
تنقص عنه قليلا
اوتيها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مكان
الزبور الذي
اتيه موسى اوتيه داود عليه السلام
وان المثاني
وهي
ما بين المئين والمفصل اوتيها النبي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم مكان الانجيل
قال وفضلت بالمفصل
وفضلت بالمفصل
العلماء اختلفوا
في
المفصل من اين يبتدئ
المفصل
القسم المفصل من
القران ما يكثر الفصول فيه
يعني الفصل بين السور
يكثر في هذه السور
والذي عليه الجمهور ان المفصل يبتدئ من
سوره ق
وقال بعض العلماء من الحجرات فهذه السوره
هي
على الحاجز وبين
المفصل
وبين المثاني
يقول الله تعالى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وهي كما ذكرنا
سوره مدنيه
والسور المدنيه
ملامحها واضحه
بمن كثر نظره في
المكي والمدني
صور المكيه يغلب عليها
قصص الايات
يغلب عليها
شده الاسلوب
ومخاطبه الناس باعتبارهم مؤمنين او كافرين
ولا ياتي ذكر للنفاق لان النفاق كان امرا
حدث بعد هجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
صور المكيه في محاده لمن عاند الله سبحانه
وتعالى ورسله والسور المدنيه
يغلب عليها
طول الايات الايات عاجزه تكون طويله
وتتكلم في تفاصيل الديانه وتفاصيل
العبادات
والسور المكيه فيها ذكر
فيها ذكر لمجمل
احكام الاسلام صور المدنيه فيها تفصيل هذا
المجمل
كذلك السور
المكيه
فان الغالب فيها مخاطبه المؤمنين يا ايها
الذين امنوا
والتفصيل بين الايمان والاسلام الى غير
ذلك
الذي عليه جمهور العلماء بلغ كاد ان يكون
اجماعا للعلماء قاطبه عن اخرهم
وهو الذي استقر عليه رايه المفسرين وراي
العلماء بعد القرون الثلاثه الاول
ان المكي ما نزل قبل الهجره والمدني ما
نزل من القران بعد الهجره
وهو
اشاره الى الزمان وليس الى المكان
فاذا قلنا هذه سوره مكيه قد تكون نزلت في
غير مكه هذا لا يهمنا الذي يهمنا انها
نزلت في العهد المكي قبل الهجره
وما كان من السور المدنيه فهذه فهذه
التسميه ايجار الى الزمان يعني بعد الهجره
في العهد المدني وليس اشاره الى المكان قد
تكون الصوره انزلت في مكه وهي مدنيه
فعلى كل حال هذه الصوره مدنيه واضح جدا
ملامح
صور المدنيه في هذه السوره تتكلم هذه
الصوره وتامر
بالاداب مع امر الله ورسوله
وكذلك الاداب فيما بيننا والتواضع وعدم
التجسس وعدم
التنابز بالالقاب ولا يستحقر مؤمن مؤمنا
والا يستحقر قوم قوما وهكذا وهذه الاداب
لابد ان تكون فيه في مجتمع يفلح واما
المجتمع الفاسد فهو الذي يكثر فيه
الغل ويكثر فيه الحسد ويكثر فيه
الطعن وهكذا
يقول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا لا
تقدموا بين يدي الله ورسوله واتقوا الله
ان الله سميع عليم
قوله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا هذا
النداء ياتي كثيرا في القران قد جاء
باسنادا معضل عن ابن مسعود رضي الله عنه
انه قال
اذا سمعت الله يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا
فرعها سمعك فاما انه خير تؤمر به او شرط
هنا عنه
فيا ايها الذين امنوا فيه نداء للمؤمنين
بان يقوموا بواجب ايمانهم يعني هذا الذي
يدعي الايمان فلا بد ان يقوم بهذا الذي
سياتي بيانه بعد هذا النداء حتى يكون حقا
من اهل الايمان وانه لن يكون
ايمان احدنا كاملا
اكتملا حتى نقوم بما جاءت في هذه في حتى
نستجيب
لدعاء الله سبحانه وتعالى في هذه الايه
فهو يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا علمنا يقينا
انه ما سياتي بعده فانه من جمله الايمان
يعني الايمان يقول ناقص حتى
يجتنب احدنا الذي سننهى عنه في الايه او
نقوم
بما سياتي
امرا في الايه فيقول تعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا هذا فيه دليل ايضا على ان الايمان
ليس فقط في القلب الايمان
اذا قلنا يؤمن بالله
قلنا هذا يدخل الجنه بالايمان لا يدخل
الجنه الا المؤمن المقصود ليس فقط الذي
يصدق في قلبه
ولكن الذي يصدق بقلبه
واعماله تصدق تصدقه
فهذا الذي يدخل الجنه بالايمان الايمان
ليس مقصورا على قول القلب بل الايمان في
القلب وايضا في اللسان وايضا في الاعمال
الانسان يكون بالايمان
الايمان ليس فقط في القلب الايمان في
القلب وفي الاعمال وتعريف الايمان
المشتهر بين الناس ان الايمان هو التصديق
لكن هذا تعريف ناقص
لقلنا الايمان هو التصديق طيب ايش الفرق
بين الايمان والتصديق
لقلنا ما في فرق اذا
هذا فيه نظر لماذا لان اسلوب القران يدل
على ان
ان ثم فرقا بين الايمان والتصديق
فمثلا الله عز وجل يذكر الايمان
وايضا ياتي باللام فيقول يؤمن لكذا
وما انت بمؤمن لنا ولو كنا صادقين وياتي
يؤمن بالله
فايش الفرق الفرق ان الايمان هو التصديق
الجازم الذي لا يتطرق اليه شك
الايمان يختلف عن التصديق بمعنى انه
التصديق وزياده
فكل ايمان تصديق وليس كل تصديق ايمان
فالانسان الذي يؤمن بالشيء او يؤمن للشخص
وهو الذي يصدق تصديقا جازما لا يتطرق الى
هذا التصديق شك وهذا وهذا التصديق يقتضي
العمل
بمقتضى يصدق به هذا هو تعريف الايمان
الصحيح عند العلماء قال تعالى يا ايها
الذين امنوا لا تقدموا
تقدم
بمعنى
لا تتقدموا
بين يدي الله ورسوله
يعني ان يكون احدنا
سابقا لامر الله ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
لابد ان نقف وراء النور
ليس
ان نكون امام الدليل اذا كنا امام الدليل
ظللنا
ولكن نبقى وراء الدليل حتى ندل
فقوله تعالى لا تقدموا بين يدي الله
ورسوله تقدم بمعنى لا تتقدموا هذا مثل من
قدم بمعنى تقدم
يعني قدم فعل ماضي تقدم
فالمقصود اننا لا نتقدم بين يدي الله
ورسوله
وهذا يكون معنويا والمقصود اننا لا نسبق
الى امر حتى يكون لنا فيه علم عن الله او
عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لا نتقدم
امام الدليل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول القران
شافع مشافع وما حلو مصدق من جعله بين يديه
قاده الى الجنه ومن جعله خلف ظهره ساق الى
النار
والعياذ بالله
فالانسان يكون وراء امر الله ويكون بامر
الله يكون بامر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا يتقدم هنا
واتقوا الله
التقوى بمعنى الطاعه
الطاعه المقرونه بالخوف والمحبه والاجلال
ان الله سميع سميع لاقوالنا عليم يعني
عليم بافعالنا سبحانه وتعالى
فهذه الايه فيها الامر
بالائتمار بامر الله ورسوله وان الانسان
لا يتجرا على امر الله ولا يتجرا على امر
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
براي مهما كان هذا الراي
شيمه المؤمن وشعار المؤمن سمعنا واطعنا
سمعنا واطعنا نحن نسمع عن الله
ولا يجب علينا ان نفهم كل ما جاء عن الله
لما جاءها هكذا لما امر الله هكذا الذي
يهمنا ان نفهم ماذا امر الله به ثم نقوم
ماذا امر به رسول الله ثم نقوم به هذا
الذي يهمنا هذا اقل الواجب
لكن اذا نظرنا في علل الشريعه ونظرنا الى
مقاصد الشريعه شيء طيب وهذا فيه علم كثير
وعلم جم عن الله وهذا هو الميزان الذي
انزله الله على رسله
لقد ارسلنا رسلنا بالبينات وانزلنا معهم
الايمان
وانزلنا معهم الكتاب
والميزان الميزان الذي ذكره الله عز وجل
هو هذه مقاصد الشريعه والقياس والامور هذه
التي يكون
يتعلمها الانسان
من جراء تعلمه
لعلل الشريعه ولاسرار الشريعه والعلماء
كتبوا كتبا في هذا لكن هذا ليس شرطا في
الانقياد نحن لا يتوقف انقيادنا على فهم
العلل
بما امر الله بهذا لما لم يامر الله بهذا
نحن الذي يهمنا ان نفهم ان هذا حقيقه ما
امر الله به هذا حقيقه ما نهى الله عنه
وننتهي هذا هو الامر نسمع ونطيع اذا نهينا
ننتهي اذا سمعنا خبرا نصدقه قد لا نفهم
كيفيه هذا الخبر جاء جاءت اخبار في القران
وفي السنه اخبار عجيبه يوم القيامه الناس
يمشون على وجوههم وفي الدنيا تخرج على
الناس دابه تكلم الناس
يعني الاموات يتكلمون
والنار صفتها كذا والجنه صفتها كذا اشياء
لا نفهمها ولا نعقلها لكن نفهم
عامه المعنى ونصدق ونقول كما اراد الله
ولا يجب علينا ان نفهم كيفيه هذه الامور
يخبرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى بانه الله وانه
الرحمن وانه الرحمن وانه السميع وانه
العليم طيب كيف يسمع كيف يعلم هذه اشياء
لا تخصنا ولا تهمنا ولو وصفت لنا لا
نفهمها اصلا هذه اشياء لا نعقلها لكن نحن
لا يتوقف عمل المؤمن على فهم العلل وفاهم
الحكمه وفاهم
يتوقف عمل المؤمن على
فهم صحه
الخبر عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم صحه
الخبر عن الله وكذلك صفه الخبر عن الله
ورسوله
اذا جاءنا امر لا نبتدا نقوم به حتى نفهم
كيف يريد الله مني
كيف قصد رسول الله بهذا الامر فاقوم بهذا
الامر على حقيقته
اقرا عن الله اقرا عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم اسال اهل العلم اهل الذكر هم يدلونني
معنى الحديث كيك كيف العمل به العمل به
هيك هيك واقوم به
لكن لا يتوقف عملي وانقيادي وطاعتي لوحي
الله على فهم الكيفيه ولا على فهم العلل
ولا على فهم
المغزى وهذه الاشياء هذه لطائف تاتي مع
العمر
العالم
ايش هو العالم
اجتماع نقط
التقطها في حياته
ما اتاه العلم جمله لا ايش هو العالم اهل
الذكر العالم هو الذي صبر وبحث ونظر
فتاتيه الفائده فيضيفها الى الفائده
والفائده الى اخرى اختها والفائده الى
اختها حتى يصبح نهر جارفا من العلم هذا هو
العلم وهذا هو العالم
فلذلك يستطيع ان ينظر الى الشريعه وكانها
صوره مكتمله بين يديه
عامه المسلمين هم الذين يقولون سمعنا
واطعنا ولن يزال قوم مفلحين ما دام هذا هو
شعارهم سمعنا واطعنا
اذا كان شعار الانسان
اطعت بعد
الفهم اذا كان الشعار لماذا لماذا امر
الله بهذا لماذا ماذا اراد الله بهذا مثلا
لماذا لم يامر الله بها هذا شعار الهالكين
شعار المؤمن سمعنا واطعنا لقننا الله هذا
الشعار فنحن نصدق ولا يتوقف التصديق على
الفهم التام والانسان لا يحتاج الى الفهم
حتى يستفيد من الشيء اي عنا السياره اكثر
الناس ما يفهم كيف السياره بتشتغل ولا كيف
المبرد يشتغل ولا كيف المي بتيجي ولا كيف
لكنه يستفيد من هذه الاشياء كلها لماذا
لانه عنده يقين اذا سحب المفتاح وحط
السياره بتشتغل عنده يقين بهذا الشيء
فيستفيد لكن الانسان اذا ما عنده يقين
واراد فقط ان ينظر كيف هذا وكيف هذا لماذا
هذا
ولا يسلك الطريق الصحيح في هذه الاسئله
ولا تكون هذه الاسئله موقوفه على الادب
الصحيح فانه يزل ويهلك والعياذ بالله يا
ايها الذين امنوا لا تقدموا بين يدي الله
ورسوله واتقوا الله ان الله سميع عليم
اسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا واياكم
ممن يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسنه
تلاقي
سوره الحجرات سوره الحجرات
القران
سوره الحجرات
الحجرات اني
حجره انا حجره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الحجرات من الشاكر
ان شاء الله تعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
مكه مكه
يعني المدينه
[Silence]
على مكه مكه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله عرفت
الله سبحانه وتعالى عسكريه
[Silence]
المكان
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى كما
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى شوف
ماسنجر
[Silence]
وهو اعلم وصلى الله وسلم